we're now going to talk about the Maurya
Empire which is not just one of the
greatest empires in Indian history and
really the first truly great Empire it's
also one of the great empires of world
history and just for a little bit of
context we can see where it fits in and
the large arc of ancient Indian history
and in particular we see here the life
of Buddha and the actual dates of
Buddhas life are under some debate but
we can see that his his life and his
teachings were roughly 150 to 200 years
before the establishment of the Maurya
Empire which lasts for another hundred
and fifty or so years and this is
important to keep in mind because as
we'll see Buddhism has a strong
influence on the Maurya Empire and may
be just as important the Maurya Empire
has a very large influence on spreading
Buddhism in a very significant way so
let's zoom in on what the Indian
subcontinent looked like near the end of
the 4th century BCE so in most of North
India you have control by the Nanda
Empire which had its capital at the city
Pataliputra which was in the region or
the kingdom of Magadha which is this
ancient region that has been the seat of
power in North India for some time you
also have other kingdoms like Kalinga
you have several kingdoms in South India
as well
there are counts of a kingdom
potentially quite powerful in Bengal
named the Ganga Reed I you also might
remember in our videos on Alexander the
Great that it was around this time
around 326 that Alexander came and
conquered much of modern-day Afghanistan
Pakistan as well and was at the borders
of the Nanda Empire in India and you
might also remember that that was about
the time that Alexander the Great and
his soldiers decided to stop they were
tired some accounts are that they are
fearful of trying to conquer another
Empire especially that
are from home so is also around the time
that Alexander the Great
decided to turn back and leave the
region under the control of some of his
governors and Generals and it was in
that context that the Maurya Empire
emerges and the actual events of how it
emerges are still shrouded in history a
little bit but what eventually happens
is a conqueror by the name of
Chandragupta Maurya is able to conquer
the nonde Empire and then not just the
nonde Empire but as Alexander the Great
retreats he is able to conquer some of
the territory former formerly conquered
by Alexander the Great and so this here
is a statue of what Chandragupta Maurya
may have looked like and you can see by
within a decade of establishing the
empire it had conquered most of the
nonde empire and had even reclaimed a
significant amount of land from the
greeks from what would eventually become
the seleucid empire remember Salukis was
one of Alexander's generals who
essentially sets up a dynasty in Persia
the Middle East after the death of
Alexander and Chandragupta Maurya
actually fights several battles with
Seleucus and is victorious and he
actually marries one of Seleucus
daughters but this is what essentially
establishes the Moriya sometimes
referred to or as the Mauryan Empire now
Chandragupta Maurya in 297 or roughly in
297 he he decides to become a more
devout Jain and in other videos we'll
talk about Mahavira and the Jain
religion but he essentially becomes an
ascetic and leaves the kingdom or the
Empire in the hands of his son Bindusara
now Bindusara is able to conquer more of
India in particular he
starts growing the Empire into the South
but Bindusara is not able to conquer the
kingdom of Kalinga bindusara dies in
around 273 or 272 BCE and then a civil
war erupts for who should take charge
and the Civil War is essentially amongst
the sons of Bindusara but the son who is
victorious ends up being a shoka now
Ashoka is one of if not the most
significant historical character in the
history of Indian so Ashoka is able to
take power roughly around 270 BCE after
as legend has it a fairly bloody civil
war early in his life is viewed as a
potentially cruel figure killing many of
his brothers in order to come to power
and he is set on conquering the kingdom
of Kalinga so in 260 to 261 he has a
significant war and he's able to
successfully conquer the kingdom of
Kalinga which is this area right over
here now that ends up according to
historical records and really Ashoka's
own accounts ends up becoming a
significant turning point in the life of
Ashoka and protect and potentially in
the life of India or the world because
here are his direct accounts of his
feelings about what happened
in Kalinga and we get this account from
what are known as Ashoka edicts as the
more Empire expanded under Ashoka and
had peace and prosperity
he put his edicts throughout the empire
on what are often known as Ashoka
pillars where he wrote what his beliefs
and the things that he did he would also
write them on rocks and stone throughout
the empire but this is the one where he
talks about the conquering of
and it's pretty interesting
beloved-of-the-gods
king pa da see and he refers to himself
as beloved-of-the-gods
King PA da she conquered the Kalinga is
8 years after his coronate coronation so
you see he was coronated roughly in 270
he conquers roughly in 260 to 150,000
were deported 100,000 were killed and
many more died from other causes after
the Kalinga had been conquered
beloved-of-the-gods came to feel he's
talking about himself
beloved-of-the-gods came to feel a
strong inclination towards the Dhamma so
Dhamma is the same word that we use
today Dharma and Dharma you could root
you can refer you can view it as the
cosmic order of things it also to a
Buddhist refers to the teachings of
Buddha or the Buddhist religion so
beloved-of-the-gods came to feel a
strong inclination towards the Dhamma a
love for the Dhamma and for the
instruction in Dhamma now
beloved-of-the-gods
feels deep remorse for having conquered
the Kalinga z-- so this is really
interesting you don't have a lot of
conquerors especially in ancient history
after killing several hundred thousand
or maybe being responsible for the death
of several hundred thousand for feeling
remorse about it and writing about it
and so not only is this profound to be
coming from a conqueror but also reminds
us how bloody some of these ancient wars
were but this is a turning point for him
he turns to Buddhism and he really then
becomes anti violence not just towards
humans but even towards animals he
becomes a devoted Buddhist and sponsors
Buddhist temples throughout his empire
he sends Buddhist missionaries
throughout the world and is viewed as
one of the main people responsible for
the spread of Buddhism from Europe all
the way to the Far East we already
talked about his edicts of Ashoka he
started doing a bunch of public works
projects digging of wells hospitals and
public Guardians education including for
women during his reign you have the
maximum extent of
any empire that ever ruled over India
50% larger than modern than the
modern-day country of India there are
roughly 50 million people under the
Mauryan Empire under his rule now
eventually after his death the Empire
goes under weaker and weaker rulers and
by about 184 185 BCE it falls to another
less significant dynasty in the whole
scope of history but just to appreciate
what a big deal of shoka is in the scope
of history here is a quote by HG Wells
from his outline of history Ashoka
worked for the real needs of men amidst
the tens of thousands of names of
monarchs that crowd the columns of
history the name of Ashoka or Ashoka
signs and shines almost alone a star
from the Volga to Japan his name is
still honored a lot because of his
spread of Buddhism more living men
cherish his memory today than have ever
heard the name of Constantine or
Charlemagne and just to appreciate the
impact of Ashoka even on modern day
India and this right over here is called
the Ashoka Chakra
and if you look at the flag of India the
Ashoka Chakra
sits at the center of it and this is
actually part of the the modern-day
emblem of the Republic of India because
after his turn to becoming a more
benevolent ruler he's considered as the
model ideal ruler in Indian history and
by many historians in all of history